okay sorry for the Romantic question but
what to use the most beautiful idea in
astronomy in Stellar astronomy
well
so early on you know when when I was in
high school I I was thinking like okay
well what what what do I want to do when
I'm growing when I grow up right I knew
I wanted to do astronomy but I was a
little bit torn because my interests
were definitely Stars Stella astronomy
but also chemistry I always had a
Fascination about the elements so Marie
Curie was was a a big role model
um my friend actually made a beautiful
produced a beautiful movie about the
discovery of
um of of the elements this is the
theater play but digitized uh where when
I thought I could actually kind of
relive the sort of Discovery moment that
that Marie Curie had it sent shivers
down my spine it was fantastic I mean
this is
this is the kind of thing that that I
wanted to experience
um but yeah so nuclear physics and
element creation information was really
interesting to me chemistry the elements
stars and all of that and I was like
I don't know if I ever find something
that combines all of these things
and then I ended up in Australia and I I
met this this person and he was working
on All Stars and as I was sitting in his
talk hearing about this for the first
time
it kind of it clicked all over my head
and it's like oh my God it it all fell
in place because we can use these old
stars to study the elements to learn how
they're formed we can get these clean
signatures that help us inform the
nuclear synthesis processes you know and
I know of course I need to know a lot
about stars too so it's it's like all
together and that that was sort of a
moment of magic
and then the fact that
I have now done that for 20 years this
is just like I won the lottery it all
clicked into place so
in some sense it's an it's an ongoing
love story for me if I could say it like
that where you know I found my stars my
thing and I am fortunate enough to be
able to keep doing that and I'm happy to
see where where it will take me you know
it's an evolution as with every
relationship you have to
if you don't March forward you move
backwards I'm not interested in moving
backwards so I'm I'm letting the field
and the discoveries and the findings
lead me to you know and I'm often
um
I'm I'm it's it's not hard for me to
follow sort of my hunches and sometimes
even at the telescope it's like
let's take a look at this one I have a
good feeling and then usually something
good or you know not bad
pop pops out at the end and I
um I really like that a that I have the
freedom to to do that that I'm allowed
to follow my hunches
um too many people I think are sort of
boxed in with their job or their life
that they they don't have that kind of
Freedom that that's really important to
me and I certainly try to make use of
that I also try to teach that to others
to trust them to learn you know you need
to learn your things but then you need
to also trust that knowledge and that
you have a grasp on it right you get out
what you put in
and
um being able to contribute in
meaningful ways to our knowledge about
our Cosmic ancestry our Cosmic history
um
that that's that's a wonderful thing
and in this way your personal love story
with the Stars evolves
what advice you've already spoken to it
a little bit but what advice would you
give to young people that are trying to
find the same kind of love story in
their career in their life
increasingly hard for folks to to find
that
um sometimes I feel
um that you know young people uh have
all the opportunities these days and
that's that's wonderful but it's almost
like that leads to some
what's the right word they're they're a
little bit of tired of too too tired to
make all the decisions because at some
point you need to put your eggs in a
basket and you need to be okay with that
we can't do all the things even though
we're often told you can be president
too and I think that's really important
to convey
but at the end of the day we can only
have sort of one job or one type of
profession I'm not saying you know you
need to be locked in but
um it's hard to change 180 degrees
and and so lots of people I think are
often afraid to
to really dig in at least for some time
and get the hands real dirty
and really learn from the bottom up on
one thing on one thing because they're
afraid they're missing out on on 99
other things
but life is a little bit missing out on
99 other things because we only have 24
hours in a day I
I have that feeling very often there are
so many things I would like to do many
things I would like to try to be good at
sometimes I wish I had a different job
you know because I have other interests
too but I realized okay I can only do
one thing so I have no regrets but this
is this is a general feeling that I
think
I would think most of us have but if it
lets if it stops you from really digging
drilling down on one thing to become an
expert in one thing to become really
good at one thing that you call your own
then that it just makes it difficult
and so a fulfilling life
is in part likely to be discovered in a
singular pursuit of a thing of one thing
well yeah or at least for a time yeah
for some time with your with your heart
and your hands
um because I think most people long to
own something
you know we all
I think want to leave some Legacy of
some sorts you know for our children for
Humanity for this planet
and I think it's really important for
young people to strive for that and not
lose sight or trade that for all the
opportunities because an opportunity is
nothing if you don't do anything
you need to you need to do something at
the end of the day so I chat with lots
of people about this and I often store
it by just saying hey tell me what you
don't like
because it's often much easier to to
narrow down narrow down let out what
what's not on your plate yeah and then
this way we get a little bit closer and
then it's like well why don't you take a
risk yeah and just sign up for something
for three months but that's what it
feels like that that's what it feels
like and it is that it's a risk
commitment is a risk yes because it's
you're basically sacrificing all the
other possible options but then I guess
you have to trust the magic you you
noticed in that thing yes if you notice
one thing just stick with it and then
and then maybe there's something there
right right and and this moment of
kind of feeling it in in your entire
body and mind that this is the right
thing you know getting there is is
probably really hard but if you don't
try you won't find out right the hard
stuff is the fun stuff that's also
another thing to find out and then
there's that yes somehow it doesn't make
sense uh you also mentioned that uh
you've taken a little stroll into the
artistic representation of yourself uh
can you can you speak to that for a
little bit yes
I wish I I you know had more time to do
other things
I find little little
um sideways I guess to to pursue things
that that I like besides astronomy or at
least I try to find connections and so
um some years ago I
um again with the help of of my friend
who made this Marie Curie movie uh she
and I wrote a one-woman play where I
actually portray Lisa midna who was an
Austrian German physicist nuclear
physicist I'm from Germany so I have the
right accent for that
uh and we wrote this play about this
moment of discovery of nuclear fission
again this is an absolutely critical
piece that explains my work today
and we all stand on the shoulder of
giants she was one of those Giants and
in some ways it's it's of course a way
for me to acknowledge other people's
work that have come before me it's a
wonderful way to highlight
um the contribution by a prominent woman
and the way I I do it is it's a 25
minute play in costume
where I relive for people the moment of
discovery
then I turn into myself
and then I give a 30 minute presentation
on the r process and the creation of
heavy elements because the audience can
now perfectly understand that the public
audience given the historic backdrop of
this discovery that they just lived
through my presentation
and it's it's a wonderful compliment
that almost spends 100 years from one
woman to the next passing on the torch
and
you know when we write up our results in
let's say you know magazines like Nature
and Science it's always about the
results on The Golden platter perfectly
prepared
it's the discovery is never described
only ever the results
you asked me beforehand right what does
it feel to be at the telescope in this
moment right
I'm happy to talk about this but it's no
way written ever nobody nobody really
talks about it and so having a form of
uh you know theater of the Arts to bring
this this exciting moment that that is
what we all want to experience as
scientists to a wider audience is so
profound and so rewarding and they all
love it because everyone can understand
a moment of Discovery I was looking for
something and then I found it it's like
you misplaced car keys right
or love it yes yes it everyone can put
the Glorious experiences yes the the
implications and the findings that is
much harder to understand for the for
anyone this is where the scientists work
truly lies this is our job but the
moment of Discovery is easy
and it's beautiful and it needs to be
said and so taking my audience on this
journey what is the perils what are my
worries and then ah here is the moment
of Discovery let me tell you about it it
profoundly transformed me and here
here's how it went right it it it's so
good and art is a way to reveal this
fundamentally Human Side of science yes
it's the problem with science is that's
people doing it
that's also what makes it beautiful
right I mean humans are fascinating you
know we're able to come up with these
ideas through all the struggle through
all the hardship through all the Hope
through all the search
and so the Arts a great way to to
portray that and to broadcast that right
I think this is how the audience really
should be interacting with Scientists
much less about the findings but really
more about this Yearning For answers
right I need to find these khakis I need
I need it because I need to go right
it's like now now
and that oh God here it is now I can go
my my Merry ways it's it's so relatable
yeah we just need to find more and
better ways to to do that so I hope to
turn this into also a digitized version
at some point to again make it more
accessible
I hope so too so far I'm just doing it
in person
but it's I would love it I think a lot
of people would love to see us I hope
you do just that let me ask you a big
ridiculous question you look up at the
stars you look up at the early
early Stars
so let me ask the big question that we
humans often ask and struggle to answer
what's the meaning of this whole thing
why why are we here
the biological evolution requires the
chemical Evolution for all of this to
kind of play out
and carbon played this important role
and you know in some sense we're we're
just a consequence of all of these
things being the way they are right so
maybe this is just where we are supposed
to be because you know the the laws of
physics sort of work the way they do and
um we talked much about the variety of
of everything really in certainly you
know from over here to over there and
things in the vicinity of where the sun
and the solar system formed they were
the way they were and life maybe wasn't
necessary consequence of that
I in some sense I like to believe that
because then it becomes reproducible and
we can apply that same argument
elsewhere if it's total chance right
that makes it harder and that's not not
truly satisfying to to a scientist
so it's uh as a consequence
of psychological Evolution which is the
consequence of biological evolution
which is consequence of chemical
Evolution consequence of physical
Evolution whatever whatever disciplines
it's uh turtles on top of turtles
turtles all the way down yes
I I
studied some of the most ancient turtles
yes at the very bottom of the thing
that's right they live for quite a while
yeah they do
well uh thank you for your incredible
work thank you for uh highlighting both
The Human Side and and the Deep
scientific side it's just I'm a huge fan
of your work and thank you for
everything you do and thank you for
talking today this is awesome of course
it was wonderful thank you